the data on kovid has been looking so
good recently but is there now another
twist in the first two weeks of the year
the seven-day average of cases for the
uk more than halved but then leveled off
sharply with cases still far higher than
last january's peak new research gives
us some clue to what's going on
scientists behind the react one study
test around 100 000 people in england
every few weeks whether or not they've
got symptoms and their latest results
show that in adults young and old coed
rates soared before christmas driven by
omicron but have been falling since the
new year but that fall has now been
cancelled out by the rise in children
since they went back to school almost
eight percent one in every 12 had
coveted at the time the scientists were
testing in adults rates were lower
between two and a half and five percent
for different age groups so why are
children and adults out of sync well the
researchers think in december children
were still being infected with delta
omicron was racing through adults
because the vaccine was less protective
against the new variant now omigron has
pushed out delta and children are
vulnerable while the virus is coming up
against a wall of immunity in adults
[Music]
it's the second time nine-year-old sully
has come down with covid he had it last
summer now he's off school again it's
not unusual two-thirds of people testing
positive in the new study said they had
been infected before
i think at the rate his school friends
were coming down with it i wasn't overly
surprised when he tested positive for a
second time
and when you look at things logically
sully's age group are the only ones who
aren't vaccinated and aren't wearing
masks the hospital data so far is
looking better with a dip in admissions
but they could rise again if the virus
spreads from children to their parents
and then on to other adults but rates
are still a long way off from the levels
you get from flu the winter of 2018 was
the last bad year the hospitalizations
in england for flu peaked at 758 in a
week in just the last seven days there'd
been 11 000 admissions for covid it's
not yet like flu at all